good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast I have returned I am
I'm almost there but I just I couldn't I
could not stand another day I'm like I'm
never here I'm a deadbeat Cabos and the
day said I'm here I can't even be here
but honestly you seemed better than ever
yesterday on your Instagram story so
here's the funny story was did an S hey
so I went to the doctor finally I do
this thing when I get sick where I'm
like I self-diagnose and I usually think
it's strep and I'll just like get myself
amoxicillin that I have left over in my
medicine cabinet and I did that this
time and I was getting worse so I'm like
day 3 I was like okay I will go to the
doctor and I didn't have strep I have
like a bacterial some [ __ ] and she gave
me a pack and I just assumed it was a
z-pack cuz like what other packs are
there you know and I've gotten packs
before where it's like seven six five
four and it was a pack so I was needed
she passed so I took the z-pak and for
the first time in like four days I felt
so much better I couldn't believe like
the magic of modern medicine it had
truly blown my mind and I and I know
that they're like steroids impact so I
was like I get why it's like a temporary
high but I was just so grateful for this
feeling and I was literally being an
advertisement like a walking face see
packs and then a bunch of people DM me
that the thing that I was showing is not
C packs its prednisone um which is
actually just like a steroid that makes
you so hungry and it doesn't let you
sleep and they're so right I've never
been more hungry in my entire life and I
didn't sleep a wink damn I'm sorry but
still it cannot complain yes when I
think about like you're on steroids
right now and I'm gonna dead I'm Lloyd
and bro yeah I'm writing
yeah I'm juicing my throat's still
really hurts I watched a doctor after
this again the break that we have coming
up while we're on hey this next week
like couldn't be coming at a better time
I feel like I really just like push my
body to the edge physically like I had
so many like so much this was supposed
to be off this month and I just like
took a bunch of random trips like worked
so much and I suppose be taking a break
like what what uh yeah you need to
listen to your body
no big logs are true you need to slow
down I do you need to listen to your
body you need to go to the North Shore
anniversary sale and become a blogger no
totally and I need to put teeth in my
hair just
inside subgroup jokes yeah I love
subgroup jokes but thank you everyone
for your well wishes in the darkest of
times here's what I learned you always
learn something from every experience in
life and on day three when I got the
prints all and maybe two hours later I
felt almost 50% better I was so weak and
so sick like I was so miserable like
been literally had to come home on his
lunch break
take the O out because I couldn't and
literally physically pick me up from the
bath I could not get out of the bath it
was horrible
and then I just felt better and it's
like you take all these things for
granted like your physical and your like
your health you know and now I just have
this like newfound appreciation for just
like my bodily functions like that I can
wake up every day and [ __ ] swallow
you know yeah like and I feel as though
as human beings we don't thank God
enough for our our physical capabilities
you know like you don't think about how
grateful you are for something until you
lose it yeah and thankfully I got it
back I'm swallowing right now
it still hurts a little but like I'm so
[ __ ] grateful I'm grating it there's
a lesson to be learned here also I think
it's helpful that you live with a doctor
like having his medical advice and how
is he feeling
he is always also so sick the day that I
got sick crazy I woke up to 9 6 huge
piles of vomit all over my apartment and
I'm like gagging cleaning up after him
I'm like who's the master here you know
it's like I'm [ __ ] sick and I'm
scrubbing the carpet with my odor and
stain removing spray it was torture but
we both were covered together we both
were covered nicely and now we're
looking forward to finishing up our
recovery into the weekend
timewise it wasn't great because I
missed so many toasts but now I'm
looking forward to like really taking
this weekend to just like listen to my
body and go to the Nordstrom sale yeah
next week because we are off next week
we're going on vacation finally I get a
vacation it's like you know I'm working
I'm really up here doing shows yeah my
channel just for life sold out
Charleston Friday night not till the
Apple like almost sold out so head over
to Carl's no job contest
snatch a few honestly those were the two
shows that I actually really wanted to
go to really I want to go to Montreal
because I
want to see it and then Lauren Lieberman
can do my makeup and brush it out there
do your makeup for yours I totally
should
Brian Kelly says that maybe I'm getting
sick oh my god I'm sick Brian Kelly says
that my gel it says favorites like one
of his favorite cities and I've heard
great things it's like mirrors room he
does and then I really want to go to
Charleston also fry a multitude I am
dying to go to Charles like to do
research for the farm gem in life to
hang out with the calves of southern
charm did Shep let you know if he's
gonna come I don't think he's gonna be
able to come but I don't really care
because me and Margo have likes we
planned out our week yesterday likes
flights and stuff and we've we're doing
something kind of crazy cuz usually what
we do is like we go from town to town to
town and then go home but it's like we
have one off day and usually we would
spend that off day in the other town
like get to know Charleston but instead
we're coming home for the night we're
going to the John Mayer concert and I
feel as though it's a really good
decision because I was not gonna let the
John Mayer concert just fly by like I
went two years ago and I know I like
that is I think when I realized Ben must
actually really like me because I was
being such an animal it's a sit-down
concert like everyone sitting down I was
standing up with the biggest vodka soda
in my hand I drink vodka back then like
sloshing it around the people the guy
next I'm seeing so loud like everyone
around me like totally won't just stab
me in the neck and been just like sat
and didn't say anything I'm like -
Daniela me and it was literally the best
show I've ever been to Mike and it's
just so great to go to a show where like
you unintentionally know the entire
discography you know yeah so I wasn't
gonna miss it and I wasn't gonna let
snitch snitch miss the opportunity
either yeah I've never seen it that'll
be fun I think you guys are adding to
your own torture but we are we are hi
Margaret when we're in like action
cities were longer than we have to be
it's a source to tell room you know this
is so stupid you didn't mention the most
important part that in order to get from
aa child choice and you have to do a
layover at LaGuardia so we're like we're
gonna be in LaGuardia let's just stay
there for the night okay fair yeah we're
like travel agents now
cool well I can't wait for all your good
times yeah I'm excited for Charlson
tickets available also job huh
oh speaking of me being thirsty I know
it's some of you guys like not that many
people ask I guess it even shipped that
many times but I'm supposed to release
my songs on my birthday and my birthday
came about and this song just like
melodically wasn't really where I wanted
but today and I'm not just gonna really
a song for the sake of like releasing a
song it's like a piece of [ __ ] so in the
past couple like well week I've been
like really working on the song with the
songwriter with the producer and like we
have really gotten into a place that I'm
like super proud of there's a couple
more edits but I have officially decided
that August 2nd is gonna be the release
date now that I've said it I have to
keep it this I released a little snippet
on my Instagram and like I think it's
good just because like I think like my
[ __ ] is gold do you know like I just
think that whatever I do is amazing it's
called confidence look up and the
reception I've gotten from the song
little snippet that I had from the
chorus that I realized has like made me
feel like I'm not crazy like it's
actually a good song yeah it's a great
song it's not and I feel as though we
are good judges of songs yeah you two
are definitely like songs but by heavily
involved in these radar kind of sort yes
every time we've gotten a new like demo
I've sent it to everyone I'm like send
me edits yeah it's really great I'm such
a collaborative process and it's just
it's gonna add to the community this is
what we need as a community I couldn't
agree more that's it community this is
so gonna add to the community like this
song it's not I mean it's obviously for
me but like it's for the toaster it's
like we just need a song like we used so
many toasty anthems like greatest
showmen but like none that we can like
own a copyright to you know and play on
the show oh it's like this is free you
[ __ ] run with it
enjoy wow that's so exciting well yeah
we're happy to have you back we're happy
you're feeling better I'm really happy
to be back I'm so grateful to be able to
swallow and just like not have a back
ache the back ache is the worst you know
do you do that like when you get sick do
you just do the thing we're like you
compare to other illnesses I'm like I
wish I'd a migraine right now sometimes
but for me I'm just always having a
migraine like anytime I have something
honest dude like food poisoning Judyann
mouth okay that's tough but my green
like a hardcore light sensitivity or
like strep throat can't swallow back
ache flu-like symptoms I think migraine
but I don't know I've never had strep
Wow
what I have they had it maybe over 20
times
we'll throw takes like what you had but
it's never been categorized as stress
well meet mark Mia Marie you and I both
get strep like so much and we really do
need to get our tonsils taken out why
don't we do it about dirt while we're on
he's a three week process and I just
don't have the time I might do it after
the beacon like I just my life can't Stu
I can't do anything I can't get pregnant
I cannot breathe I'm a bit don't even
look at me when's the last time you had
stress like six months ago I get it all
the time but you just keep thinking that
you're getting it just like this time no
I had a lesson
how do you know this one's a doctor okay
tell me that amoxicillin suite well we
have so much to discuss today obviously
the news of the day recapping Beverly
Hills and southern charm and also just
some things that went on this week
they're like I want to talk about that
I'm sure you guys are but they did like
Austin Butler as Elvis Presley so
[ __ ] here for it really sad that's
Harry Styles didn't get it but there's
no rumors that he's gonna be Prince Eric
in the Little Mermaid and I feel as
though that's the perfect role for him I
feel as though all this conversation
around the casting everyday I look for
stories and it's like so-and-so rumored
to be playing contra el rey like every
it's like sit why is this like a raise
your hands sort of known as when did
like the public become a casting agency
no it's so crazy like every single day
there's stories about who's gonna play
who who wants to play whoo-hoo-hoo
they're talking to you and like I just
don't understand why it's such public
knowledge no it's it's weird that like
the public has such a heavy influence on
the casting couch it's it's just a weird
thing and now it's making the movie
bother me mm-hmm
I'm bothered so would you say I mean I
don't have a watch or anything but I
think it's time I don't know snitch okay
what are the people saying talked about
a lot and it's only been 10 minutes
who's talking about your ability to
swallow know it cuz you know what it's
so great well it is time for the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
however we would be remiss if we didn't
let you know that today's episode is
brought to you by MTV's the real world
Atlanta streaming now on Facebook watch
the original reality show is back and
streaming now only on Facebook watch MTV
some real world Atlanta is the next true
story of seven strangers picked to live
in a house and have their hookups
screw-ups apologies fights tears voices
and lives
streamed exclusively on Facebook watch
it's the return of the first unscripted
show in TV history that tackled gender
race AIDS
booze life death addiction connection
acceptance and reality and it's being
reinvented MTV's the real world Atlanta
is an all-new reality experience with
content dropping daily and new episodes
every Thursday find out what happens
when the next generation stops being
polite and starts getting real again in
facebook click on the facebook watch
icon and stop and search the real world
on watch MTV's the real world Atlanta
streaming now only on Facebook watch I
saw the first episode like a month ago
and it was honestly [ __ ] trippy and
like really made me think how I would I
think I would rather die than live in a
house with seven strangers I think they
did it for like three months and you
would have to stop being polite and
start getting real that's a thing and I
am a lot of things but I am real no
you're not going no what's in this
coffee did the B have all the
ingredients to ever see I see
I mean EBC EBI everything but I think oh
wait I want you I know we like you I'm
sure you guys already talked about him
can we talk my Vegas for one second sure
yeah I want to get your recap I've
looked here what was your eyes his
highlight of the trip uh I said Friday
night you said chaos I said the pool
party yeah
- Adele's oh yeah right yeah but yeah
head and because I feel like we did big
it's different this time you should go
to Vegas and like a blackout order room
service blackout again go home
but this time I feel like we had much
more of a culinary experience and be in
an amazing dinner at Zuma and then
Saturday I was like really contemplating
whether or not to schedule a brunch I
just figured people would want to sleep
in and then go to the day party I didn't
know if it would be like a huge
inconvenience but I am so glad we did it
first of all they set up the most
beautiful private dining room for us
like we were improve on we were
literally in the lavender fields of
Provence we were at the Chateau that
sophie Turner got married in and the
drapes were toasty they were pink leaves
with green background like it was so big
that like Richard shouts aw I was so
good make another reference yes that's a
great restoration also that's a great
reference when I walked in a migrate but
it's gonna take forever yeah food walked
in there was literally
tiered trays of croissants and there was
- let's just [ __ ] chocolate right I
ever had the food didn't stop coming
there was a bar in the corner like they
took such good care of us I just like I
was like this is what it's like to be
Megan Markel like it was the most
stunning premium experience and I cannot
thinks Adele's enough because like it
was [ __ ] epic yeah I really felt like
a famous person the suit starts coming
and it don't stop it didn't stop did you
guys want dessert we're like no you need
that
yeah like smash mash yeah oh wow what
now when you were here what I've been
finding myself doing this a lot and like
I hate I blame me for it I hate it I
hate it I hate it it's just a face okay
not for me because like now it is Who I
am for the podcasters it's us rocky this
is also face its index and pinky this is
the best this is camper on snapchat Yeah
right right right by the way is kissy
face and peace sign it's also it's also
Loretta no that's really where we got
him yes camber is so inspired by Lorenz
she's heard generate like she's her icon
but after that I would say Friday night
was my night cuz like I was out till 6
in the morning and that literally gave
me strep throat and I I would say it was
almost worth it like I know the feeling
it was such a good night and I'm so
upset because I literally don't remember
like so much of it and I know I was
having the best time like I just loved
it blow and like really our friend
Nicole Brookman who would like is his
number one fan like made me like himself
I was saying she gave me such a music
education yeah like when we were at
stagecoach and Diplo it's after party
she was like literally gonna drive from
LA she's like his biggest fan and she
was I was like what is the fandom like I
don't get it is just like a DJ but now
after like thoroughly investing in him
in his career and his personality like I
can say I am a Diplo Stan and I just
think he's like so cute and funny and
like I love that he's like so leaning
into the country they can everywhere he
goes he's dressed this country like yeah
he looks like Lola it's like I love him
love and I'm glad we got to see him you
know we didn't talk about yet the old
town of remix with me listen ramsey oh
my god flames truly so [ __ ] good and
young thug's on the song - you like the
new remix and it's crazy but I think
Mason like out wrapped him
Oh mister chorus but but it I have never
seen two videos of Mason singing the
song where he can't remember his own
verse what's in front of a crowd and one
Saigon snapchat when he like flub to the
words whatever there's just one line
that I haven't made out yet exercise
like improvise that it's like how bono
raised or who had it Sonique oh there's
something it sounds odd of thousand-acre
sounds like he's talking about his
counselor he's like doing it to the
counts and yeah I heard that too
if you ain't got no giddyup they gave ya
away
wrote that deserves a 1 million dollar
rate no whoever wrote that deserves a
Grammy I hope that this song never stops
having Ritter reiterations like okay
what's that Dolly Parton thing real yes
he between the Dolly Parton first she
responded then he was found again I'm
telling the tapping and he also the
church Mariah Carey on Twitter and she
said yes okay so then Dolly Parton
should be dropping tomorrow because they
put out the artwork with her on a with
her pink horse and I just I'm love I
didn't know that they need to leave a
little bit more space like we need to
enjoy the Mason Ramsey one a little bit
more I don't know maybe they just come
out with new ones there's something for
everyone like I don't know that I'm
gonna listen to the eggshell listen they
got like Willie Nelson yeah but like not
everyone's gonna listen to the Dolly
Parton one actually everyone's gonna
listen to all of them I mean I didn't
think this song could get any better or
like being more relevant and it's
definitely still number one still nobody
need actually check last night in the
get up which is just you've got number
two number one I have to be on billboard
I just checked my iTunes it's not real
on Billboard even the Billy eyeless
Justin Bieber thing debuted at number
two and literally nothing can be item
for Justin Bieber ed Sheeran both of
Taylor Swift songs all debuted at number
two it's hilarious it's hilarious and
you want to know what's the craziest
thing is the Billy Ray Cyrus of it all
because I happened to stumble upon some
documentary about Billy Ray in Vegas and
I had already been thinking this but
like in his day he wasn't one-hit wonder
and achy-breaky heart was the old town
road of his time and like not only does
the one-hit wonder not always have a
long career but to be a tuner with two
completely viral songs that have swept
the nation like 50 years of it's
literally lightning striking in the same
place twice
that is so true I didn't even think of
it that way you know like because
anybody heart was such like oh I mean I
wasn't there for it but such a cult song
it is what Old Town Road that's very
interesting comparison so for him and
then also like lightning struck a third
time with Hannah Montana Oh Jake Owen
wrote Mason Ramsay's verse and he's
staying on it too but they chose Mason
Ramsay any tweeted no hurt feelings but
he's okay so he should get that million
dollars money Calle yeah Wow I have no
better set for Jay Cohen well I always
had a sore spot
I went to see him at a concert at
Madison Square they actually
Unwin and honestly it was a wonderful
experience because no I'm really when
and system it's a nice park you know
it's not one of the dirty parks and I
had a great time it's such a clean park
I can't believe they let you have a
concert they're like yeah Larry the
cleanest Park in the city
honestly only marginal grass they should
be more [ __ ] like that I got a hundred
person concert that would be so nice
it was lovely in a mayor pin country
love something like no sing-along Wow
okay now are you ready oh we still
haven't done he started what else did
you want to talk about that you missed I
think that was it it keeps coming to me
but like those were the top of mine
awesome but Larry me good news starts
coming in and don't stop coming exactly
the maze news we don't actually have
some things needs today
actually this piece of news is like so
upsetting like we just like run right
through Easter but yeah I guess just
like they breeze through this case
sexual assault case against Kevin Spacey
has been dropped by prosecutors bode
called this we there was murmurs of this
last week I guess Andy has also been
predicting this but the sexual assault
case against Kevin Spacey has been
dropped
according to Massachusetts prosecutors
the decision was made quote due to the
unavailability of the complaining
witness said Cape and Islands district
attorney Michael O'Keefe in a document
filed Wednesday Spacey 59 had been
accused of groping an eighteen year old
man in July 2016
the former busboy refused to speak in
court earlier this month invoking the
Fifth Amendment after being questioned
by the house of cards stars lawyer about
text and snap match snapchat messages
that could prove the actor's innocence
he initially didn't he initially denied
deleting the messages wow that's a
tongue twister which according to
Spacey's attorney Alan Jackson could
possibly prove he consented do you
respect the hell out of Alan Jackson not
enough apparently quote this entire face
is completely compromised Jackson said
in court this case needs to be dismissed
and I believe it should be dismissed
today this is some [ __ ] [ __ ] and
all I want to say is Kevin Spacey has
never looked worse that picture like on
the article like he looks like he's not
sleeping and he hasn't stopped eating
and I hope he just eats himself into a
big abyss of sadness this is so sad like
when this happens it takes so much like
strength and courage for people to come
forward and not only are they just
completely knocked down but then like
the next person's not going to why go
through all of this the criminal justice
system in addition to being you know
comprised of an elite squad is so [ __ ]
up
I am so over it it's like so many
terrible things are just like happening
all the time and like no one's ever
being a cat held accountable then like
read and people when they see us the
Central Park five or I go to jail for
doing this is like absolutely nothing
like I'm just so [ __ ] done when
everyone in the justice system being bad
at their jobs
no we need a civil I don't know what we
need but we need something else we need
we need Kim Kardashian but also I'm glad
that Felicity Huffman is getting you
know her do it's so job like I can't
believe that there are people just like
walking the streets like Jeffrey Epstein
has literally been walking the streets
for 50 years every person knowing that
he has an island full of little boys who
are being held their girls and girls I
mean yeah soon yeah little kids um
thanks and like finally Kevin Spacey
that's taken a cord I'm like he's just
going home back to his mansion you know
I never has to work he doesn't have to
like go like it's [ __ ] you know
what's bothering me I would like to know
okay so I saw an article last week like
everything we know about Jeffery
Epstein's like sex island it's from the
cut from the cut and exits onyx I'm like
ooh what do we know
and we're only used to seeing the island
being spoken about like on Underground
blind auntie and like even if you go
back to our old patron episodes where we
talk about blinds we always went back to
this island like it'd all be like you
know it all goes back since Island but
that's a whole nother beast but like
this island has been you know public
knowledge for a very long time and like
so I clicked on the cut article
everything that it said was just
satellite images and there was
absolutely nothing wasn't nothing burger
and everything that was there has been
stuff that NT has been saying for years
and also things that we've known for
years like the satellite image of the
temple that locks from the outside like
we've always had that image like there's
nothing new but everyone has known this
for so long and like it just really
bothers me when like it's just as though
the media or whatever just decides to
talk about something and now we're gonna
talk about it so when the information
has been there forever
there have been people saying these
things for so long and like and then a
journalist will say well we can't run
anything that we don't know to be a
hundred percent sure I'm like please TMZ
said I put two million followers the
[ __ ] media says whatever they want
they don't give a [ __ ] if it's true or
not like I've read literally the biggest
lies about myself
about people that I know like there's
absolutely no homework done when it
comes to being a journalist these days
you could take a dump and put on the
Internet
everybody like poets are so that's such
[ __ ] that they say they can't run
anything unless they have proof right
just you say alleged and then it's fine
right accused yeah actually I was
reading something about Jeffrey Epstein
they took out the Elijah it's just like
pediment really yeah nice I think it was
the post
they've been savage these days and you
know some it's it's days like today and
situations like this where the New York
Post say what you want about them
politically but with with like kind of
like salacious gossip or like criminal
whatever like the post isn't necessary
media like they're the only people who
like say it say what everyone's thinking
you know except I will never forgive
them for Trump mean Trump when they put
a picture of Kim like looking really not
great ah with Trump when she was just
trying to do some good like that really
really upset me and they say I just
didn't like that yeah but I think my
folks it's very much like a New York
specific thing oh is it I don't know the
people outside of New York well now
everyone reads page six because like I'm
housewives and like some more national
but for a while it was very like New
York centric but at least like the New
York Times is a national newspaper that
the New York Post is a little more so
you can't get the New York Post in
hotels yeah you definitely can but I
think it's just it's like this I don't
read the Chicago Tribune you know it's a
little more localized okay but I would
say that the New York Post is like a
little bigger than the Chicago Tribune
I mean never been kissed did amazing
things from the Chicago sun-times so I
would say that's the biggest newspaper
in the world ya know but anyways that
just bothered me I placed the article
and it was everything I've ever seen on
any that's just like known you know but
kind of collage around nothing out no
it's a collection of a reddit thread a
thread that's been that's been around
for years yeah right so I just hate when
people like take someone else's
information act like it's new news yeah
and get my click total I'm just mostly
mad at you look elected anything about
you fellas
cuz usually like the cuts pretty good
they always have something salacious you
know they always have a hot take yeah
anyways
upsetting about this Kevin Spacey thing
and it just doesn't make [ __ ] as
well it's been a while since we got
justice like this doesn't bode well for
you know our Kelly trial or Jeffrey
Epstein it's like Harvey Weinstein these
people they have ways of just like
getting what they want it's so [ __ ]
annoying it's like I just can't help but
think about the Lori Loughlin of it all
she'll go to jail she is she's gonna go
to jail
and like she did commit a crime but like
but not the great scale of the world
like no one was really that worse off
from Loyola flings crimes and and in the
scale of celebrity crimes because we can
compare you know Lori Loughlin to
someone who like else who committed a
crime who's gonna have to pay blah blah
blah but I'm pitting celebrity crimes
against each other here not general
crimes right and and the ones that will
most likely prosecute and go to jail are
like the the ones that had the fewest
victims yeah totally
okay next up Khloe Kardashian is doing a
vote makeup tutorial she admits to over
contouring her nose quote I look crazy
okay WL watch YouTube tutorial yeah
really cute I'm really excited for her
she's the third and final sister to do
her vote make up time Oreo surprised
that Courtney got it before her but it
was the Poosh of it all oh you think so
she had just launched bouche and she
does have like a take on beauty and not
it's not natural you know like clean I
never thought about Chloe doing her
makeup before no cuz in my mind Chloe
just gets it done and she really does
she admitted like that they pretty much
got it done every day especially while
they're filming so Chloe Kardashian on
have had her own makeup empire like
sisters Kylie or Kim but she's
definitely picked up on some tips and
tricks
the reality star revealed how she goes
from makeup free to fully ready to film
Keeping Up with the Kardashians in a
vogue in a video with Vogue and
unsurprisingly the clip focuses heavily
on contouring a favorite technique of
her family's though Chloe does contour
her entire face using Kim's rule of
three she particularly focuses on
whittling down her nose with a clever
combo of shadows and highlights
admitting she sometimes goes a bit
overboard with her application okay so
there have been like a lot of people who
have made fun of her nose like looking
like it's sinking into her face yeah but
according to this video she hasn't
really had that much done but she just
changes it and then makes you think like
why doesn't she just get a nose job yeah
it's like obviously then security
efforts that she's using eye shadow on
her [ __ ] nose I thought her nose
looked better before she contoured I do
not like the look of like a super
contoured nose I don't think a big nose
is like bad like sometimes it it works
but I think when you make your nose look
so so skinny and then like shiny on top
it looks weird yeah it looks like when
Michael Jackson like - never knows yeah
I wish she would like just stop doing
that so much but I thought she did a
nice job with her makeup I know me too
and I love just seeing her but her
bathroom was beautiful
huge vanity behind her oh my god that's
like my dream and then she's like I
locked the door and just let you run
around yeah yes and if it gets too quiet
I'll let go see what's up
no a hundred percent true is so cute
yeah really cute I was just like I
thought Chloe was being like a little
shy I think that she's not used to like
being so low like everything she does is
really either like a family thing good
American is a partnership like she's
never really the center of attention and
I do think she actually prefers it this
way so but like when she got this
opportunity obviously you're not gonna
pass it up I do think she's like
uncomfortable being on camera alone and
I think that she really was like so
honored like she's involved yes exactly
like she puts everything she's the last
sister to be invited and I feel like out
of all them she really maybe Kendall but
she like talks to the camera the least
in terms of like say like videos like
Kim and Kylie are always on their phones
like it's an unnatural to be alone
talking to a camera and unless you do it
a lot like you're weird yeah so and she
has like such a big personality in real
life that those aren't always the people
that translate no not at all so I
definitely felt the weirdness - yeah
sweet I love her like I really love her
and when she was talking about each of
the sisters and like their makeup I was
dying because yeah like she had like
those little jabs and she like said
under her breath oh yeah and that I
loved
yes she literally does her makeup all
the way down to her nipples I know I
found that so interesting when I go down
to my neck but she literally went down
to her boobies I think that's like what
yours not for your makeup before your
skincare like you really should she was
right like you really do show aging your
chat in your chest cuz our big titties
are constantly dragging or not no but
like also the next skin I just feel like
it's thin so like it's just gonna start
sagging like that yeah the first time
neck and hands hands you know oh did you
get your k'kaw Beauty pennies you know
yeah it's way oh I got my girl that [ __ ]
like two days ago but I haven't tried it
like I tried down my arm but I haven't
really I got that and Taylor merchant
like it was just such a great day
actually all I boxes came I got home
from Vegas but I was too frail to open
them so open the mall yesterday I took
my steroids and it was just like such an
exciting day I haven't used it yet but
like I gotta go somewhere now are you
gonna bring on the trip uh yes of course
cuz I cry my legs I'm gonna do it use
them use it this weekend I wanted you
something funny like I really want to
get on Kim's story cuz she shares like a
bunch of influencers she do it like I
wanna think of something funny like I
really wanted to write like something on
my leg like you're ugly and then cover
it but then what if it doesn't cover Oh
interesting like how I was sat on the
thing and she tweeted up yeah yeah okay
there's something there okay third story
some exciting news about Nikki Bella we
haven't spoken about in a while but she
has confirmed that Artem is her
boyfriend we were talking about her so
much for a while I know with John Cena
and the show was on and then she was
like The Today Show and about with our
demeanor her and John we're like off and
then on and then off again the Peter
Krause and then Peter Krause and then
they launched a podcast and now her and
Artem are official which isn't really
news because on the first episode of
their show they did say that they were
dating but now they're saying they're
boyfriend/girlfriend because it's middle
school and they like released a video of
them dancing it's literally so Viking
kid yeah I just I I'm here for Nikki
Bella's health and happiness me too
Nikki Bella and Artem Zig Vince EV are
official the WWE star confirm the
couple's relationship status on
Wednesdays episode of the Bellas podcast
appropriately titled hashtag official
we're boyfriend and girlfriend Bella
said she added we are in a relationship
the pair began seeing each other
romantically in late 2018 but did not
confirm they were actually dating until
March when the nepo sewed featured Bella
and Artem riding a motorcycle together
sweet sweet so happy like I don't think
no and now that we're like out of it I
don't think that John Cena was really
like the man for her they were just too
different and in two different places
and he was really too stubborn and he is
the type of guy who like has a specific
life like idea of what his life is gonna
be and no person is gonna change that
and she's also like super strong willed
it was just it was too much so I I hope
she's happy I like I do wish she was
dating someone like a little bit more
famous just cuz like I want her to start
her eyes a little bit but whatever like
you can't go from John Cena to like a
dancer but whatever yeah but I feel as
though her level of poverty is really so
perfectly she has a reality show she
does everything she'll go a red carpet
and be like recognized but she won't get
my pounded by paparazzi she can work as
much or as little as she wants she
chooses to work a lot but she is in
control yeah you know they have their
wine they have their clothing brand
their
right yeah wow they really have so they
do so much because they are like the
perfect brand yeah I really love them me
too I'm excited for the show to come
back and I knew they have each other in
a while it's time this whole thing was
like amazing for ratings I don't think
that's why they did it I'm not
suggesting them just saying like I'm now
so invested me too where's like I
watched total divas total divas and like
I remember when that girl Maddie got
married I was like this show sucks but I
was like so invested actually really
like Maddie and like I think she's like
she's like do you know what like her at
all which one is she like the short
problem yes that comes from a long line
oh no I've never watched her little
divas which is why it's so crazy that I
through the back door got so into total
Bellas total divas is like not good but
this girl NAT she's just like she's just
notice she's like inherently like a
loser and she tries to fight it but if
you like embrace her lose her eNOS like
she's actually like kind of funny and
cool and like I just feel like her like
she married a loser too like and they're
just like these losers I don't know how
we start talking about this but I'm glad
that we franchise I mean that they
franchise for the Bellas
ya know his total divas I don't know if
it's still on it does not have like a
long life out of it I think it is still
on because I think it's just good
messaging and programming for E it is it
doesn't matter how many of you got power
man yeah on so many different levels uh
oh my girl you actually should go to the
WWE like you're so mean that's yeah
you're a great shape like you're a
pretty girl with like good hair your
your wrestling name could be the snitch
ah oh my god I'm going in zip recruiter
and I'm applying for jobs for you you
have to start would you are you willing
to start in the mailroom like I don't
even know how to fight though they teach
you you go to Tampa and they train it in
the facility oh yeah I think that's a
great idea it's like so hard to find a
job these days but there's one place you
can go we're hiring a simple fast and
smart a place where we're growing
businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place is zip recruiter
comm and if you go to zip recruiter comm
slash toast I would say we will hook it
up for you you zip recruiter sends your
job to over a hundred of the websites
leading job boards but they don't stop
there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scan thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job so
company you go find people and if you're
a person you can find company so our
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive address zip recruiter
dot-com / toast
that's zip recruiter comm /t o ast again
zip recruiter comm / toast sip recruiter
the smartest way to hire love it
actually do you really feel like Marga
would be a great Bella no now Ava isn't
funny how like they have become so
associated I just had a Bella yeah but
really how do we not think of it sooner
and then she could be like Barbie and
she could a Cole Swindell
oh my god and there'll be a way for you
to stay in shape because like you're
always just worried about saying shape
like story what keeps you up at night
and like I can't imagine how much well
that must be because it's like [ __ ]
misery on earth ever think about it's
like that it's like the 15th thing I
think about way my friends I family
foods like where we're gonna eat next
the oh yeah so I actually feel like the
zoo and they're always like looking to
get into like the digital space we need
get like oh that's UFC who's the guy
who's the girl that they have like who
owns the WWE her family like Stephanie
or something oh I don't have known she's
always on the show like thinking fight
she's like a fake wrestler - I want to
say her name is like Steph Manning but I
know that's your nice Brett her name is
really similar to Stephanie okay my
horsing might be Manning did oh I'm
sorry oh it's good actually really well
Honolulu I came up with a good slogan
fur Oh what can you smell what the
snitch is toasting yeah I can I would
die they would eat me alive
no you would eat them alive counts yeah
at Rumble yeah okay I think yeah her
name is Stephanie McMahon so like I got
the initials right yeah that's pretty
good yeah that's hilarious okay are you
ready for our next story which is a
little business of course I'm always
ready for a little business in the
morning does it apply to me hungry no
applies to actually a little bit because
it applies to the whole world now
because we've all been using the face
app which apparently is used to hack
your phone and steal your face by the
Russians by the Russians
so the DNC warns 2020 campaigns not to
use what ASAP Margot's big WWE movie
could be throwing a toaster no they
throw
but they throw like changers she could
electrocute jump throw them in a bathtub
and then throw a toaster in we need to
make a sketch of to you and like what
your outfit would look like I'll work on
it oh my god I love it and she's super
her felis of course of course yeah
sorry continue okay the DNC warns 2020
campaigns not to use the face app
developed by Russians so we've all been
using the face app to aids ourselves
then yesterday we saw like there was
news starting to come out that this is a
Russian company and now they have your
face and what are they gonna do with it
and what Ben told me is like so when you
know when you download an app you just
accept the terms and agreements yeah so
they can use any celebrity that
downloaded the app they can literally
use that celebrity's name and likeness
to promote like any one of the brands
under the company's umbrella because
they agreed to it yes I said that
uber thing that happened was tied to
people who downloaded the app but I
downloaded and didn't use it I did not
download the app been down but you tell
them you should be there I have a
question this got me thinking so there's
a lot of difference there's a lot of
speculation as to like okay
what is the hack what information are
they interested in are they interested
in any information it's just like they
had I saw that their Terms of Service
isn't that much different than other
apps but because it's like a Russian
based company where like spooky stuff
right any time you hear the word Russian
you're like who's right and now they
have all of our pieces now can your
identity be stolen if your semi-famous
yeah really like your identity gets
stolen online I know but like then I
feel like you wouldn't be eligible for
identity theft because like if someone
Google's that person they're gonna see
that that's not you yeah but what do you
consider identity theft like when
someone like sandy Bigelow Patterson but
that's another person who like lives in
Canada whose name is Justin Bieber like
it's possible for people to have the
same name that's true I think identity
theft is more so online like credit card
right it's like a website doesn't know
that it's not LeBron James writing the
order that's true okay
damn cuz the other one seems more like a
catfish yeah like you can't catfish
using someone using someone semi-famous
cuz you'll get caught eventually
obviously
or the person is just like so dumb right
anyways I had deleted the app I have
since deleted it but they have my face
and now it's annoying for people who
didn't delete the app of people face
after them like Ben did a million people
right no Ben and I now literally sending
data to the Russians of literally every
Kardashian every member of our family
and every person we know right today I
got really carried away you thought it
was so funny they have our worst case
scenario for him yeah right we the worst
I downloaded it because of him so like
honestly if something happens like I'm
coming for Ben you should like I'm gonna
be pissed so now the DNC is worrying
presidential candidates not to download
it because then they think that the
Russians are gonna hack well yeah
because like every candidate running for
president is trying like so hard to be
like cool and young like I saw like some
lady like eating wings they're trying to
be cool and young by making themselves
older right you know what I mean like
they're trying so much like at the
Millennial vote to the point it's like
actually sad that like I'm sure every
single candidate like one of the interns
had this downloaded in five seconds like
this is more you know like it wouldn't
work cause like you know but it's just
it's funny that's actually hilarious
that that's how it came out because
everyone's trying really hard to like
reach and Lenny Laboe cuz we're just
like such a diverse and you know heart
intellectual audience that our vote is
really I cannot tell you how little I'm
looking forward to the election like
yeah everyone gets so mean and heated
and I really feel like that girlfriend
Mean Girls like I really wish we can all
just get along because I know it really
like it's a I find the elections to be
very tough on me emotionally mentally I
understand well it's not like there's
all the speculation as to what the hack
could be easy to hack there's no button
like a rumor of the hack got so blown up
yeah there's no clear it's not clear at
this point what the privacy risks are
but what is clear is that the benefits
of avoiding the app outweigh the risk
says Bob Lord the DNC's chief security
officer whose daughter is probably a
toaster Billie lourd um okay so like if
you didn't download the app
congratulations and don't download it if
you have it I'm sorry
delete it it's really like an episode of
black where yes like and how did it go
so viral
I don't know cuz it's like not that
funny like it's cool and actually you
want to know why it went viral because
it actually does it really is an
accurate representation of like what
people will look like when they're older
sometimes those apps that make you like
bald or fat like you look so dumb these
mostly look at technology yeah our
hyper-real like good quality and very
realistic yeah it's like they are
something interesting so when I did my
picture and honestly I'm gonna age like
a raisin apparently but they didn't
account for the GZ factor where like I'm
not gonna let that happen
um I did actually you see how much
trouble yes wearables recap with Rob oh
I love her so much they did the aging
where you can look younger and I did one
where I look younger and I looked like
so beautiful obviously because I was
young but I realized that main
difference was that they really filled
out my eyebrows like made them thicker
and a little darker and it made like a
really nice difference well I've just
got the Kylie eye brow hybrid this
morning and I highly recommend it I
might be a shade darker thanks to the
Russians wow thank you
maybe that was the point of all this
they were able to show me what I
couldn't see myself maybe this was an
elaborate plan you know put together by
all the trolls who tell you to fill in
your eyebrows more yeah and you know
what you guys finally I've heard you I
just need to proof that it would make me
look better
11:11 make a wish that no other cases
just fall shy of evidence and letting
predators get off the hook and I wish
for the ability to swallow for the rest
of my life and that goes for all the
people that I love I was shut you know
this hacking like really isn't as bad as
it could be you know Michio cuz like
weird I did and then if they use my face
it's like only like they're not selling
like herpes cream or something you know
that was me Jackie you know what can you
do me a favor
you know friends is leaving in 2019 yeah
I think you should watch it you're going
on a trip like it's so light-hearted you
could just put it on in the background
it really is like just like jokey funny
like you will really enjoy it we would
have such a good time and it's leaving
in six months like I really I I implore
you to to watch it and Jackie you give
her show Fahey's yes
okay I will watch Mad Men no but I don't
think that you would like you should be
tell me my trend since you think I'll
enjoy it I do but if you could get past
your own stubborn wall okay I don't
think you would enjoy Mad Men okay I
want you to watch like something I want
you to watch like one season I'll pick
the best season of are you the one fine
done that's good right yeah you're gonna
love it
but you have to watch like the ten
seasons of friends yeah yeah oh I can't
with Chauncey yes you got all seasons of
are you the one fine because um friends
season one is like really awkward sitcom
because I call just getting to know each
other but a picks up speed and it gets
to a place where like they're literally
a family and like you could tell they're
all that like just watch it okay right
on season three but I'm gonna go back
once I think it was like yeah Rachel's
hair is like just so not it and Monica's
is like and Monica has buzz cut okay are
you ready for a fifth and final story no
I had thought Margo that I wanted to run
by you it's a friends conspiracy theory
that conspiracy theory but more so just
thought because I was just watching
running up to I'm at the end of season 9
or Monica and Chandler
Jaggi put over years they're together
they're trying right now they just
they're just are they big I heard you
but I thinking okay and then like when
Margo is like a spoiler show yeah Hobbes
if I tries to ruin it
he really was too good for Monica I'm
glad that they didn't end up together
late oh man what are you talking about
Richard they end up together wait what
are you talking about I think it said
Chandler and Monica
yeah then Richard was too good for
Monica 100% like the fact that he even
liked her so and he's talking about this
alright okay sorry no Richard Tom
Selleck like he needed to be with she
looks wise like they were perfect
together because like Courtney Cox like
it's so [ __ ] beautiful especially
like in her prime of friends like I just
look at her and I hate her character but
she's so beautiful but like she was so
goddamn annoying Richard was just like
this rich optometrist who lived uptown
and smoke cigars and Monica was just
like trash from Johnson it would have
made no sense we have to him end up
together if he was introduced in season
1 what we watch 10 seasons event right
and like how would the group have
survived if Monica and Chandler had
broken up the group and then Monica
moved uptown
yeah and Monica and Ross are really like
the core of the group because they're
brother and sister right yeah that's a
tough one
yeah sorry ok ok I'll get into it so
anyways our fifth story a little TV news
hello
Gossip Girl reboots gets series morning
on HBO max by the way what I heard about
this at first I'm like it
then I heard upset HBO and I'm like [ __ ]
yeah and it's with Ben Schwartz and
Stephanie Savage
who's that they're the ones who made
gospel and they make nasty I think I
know what I'm saying if they did this
unlike CW
some another trash and I thought you
went out I'd be like whatever HBO only
turns out premium [ __ ] content yes
agreed and they're gonna use like social
media like the evolution of social media
is like probably a way that Gossip Girl
got yeah I won't have a blog right which
makes a lot of sense because like those
alerts we're a little fishy right and
it's like it's a website but it's
getting to your flip phone like guys
that make sense right even alert from a
website on a flip phone no but everyone
can check Instagram right Gossip Girls
making another comeback Warner Media
soon to launch streaming service HBO max
has ordered ten hour-long episodes of a
reimagined version of the pop-culture
phenomenon that made household names of
stars such as Blake Lively Leighton
Meester Penn Badgley chase Crawford and
Ed Westwick the project hails from the
original series writer and executive
producer Khurana co-creator Joshua
Safran Josh Schwartz and Stephanie
savages fake empire alloy entertainment
Warner Brothers TV and CBS Studios Wow
sounds like a smash like the original
series the new iteration of Gossip Girl
written by Safran is based on the book
by Cecily von Ziegesar the logline
eight years after the original website
went dark but Leslie Vaughn's ooh Lazar
who literally is so rich from this one
series of books no and but she deserves
it yeah tell des brighter eight years
after the original this is the premise
eight years after the original website
went dark a new generation of New York
private school teens are introduced to
the social surveillance of Gossip Girl
The Prestige Series will address just
how much social media and the landscape
of New York itself has changed in
intervening years that sounds really
good I'm glad there he does making it
like Blair and Serena again know are
they gonna be in RAM it's gonna be
called Gossip Girl I think will be
called Gossip Girl I think the
characters should have new names then
yeah really
eight years after so who are we casting
as like the wire on this no it's
probably gonna be like people we've met
we don't know
lame Easter and Serena van der Woodsen
like who what up-and-coming blonde and
brunette actresses are we gonna throw in
there I don't know I feel like like
she'll be a Carson I hope like nobody
for me she'd be really good you know but
like it's like they're too like safe and
this was probably like a little bit
they're gonna be like doing cocaine yeah
I think it's gonna be an edgy film
because now that I think about it I
don't know what like New York teens are
up to these days but are they up to
Margaret they're insane are they they
are yes by doing
right yes like dropping acid for sure my
toes saying I like when like in prep
school not like my odds no it might like
Jewish school has always been like yeah
I really like my AJ we're doing like
drugs when I was in high school I go to
my school like a couple boys in my grade
like smoked weed on their lunch break
and it was like the craziest thing yeah
I mean they're insane now it's crazy
yeah now they're probably just like high
all the times you bad for their parents
they probably can't even like begin to
try and handle them
dan so wait okay who are we casting
seriously that's like the blonde perfect
like like who's just I'm deaf Kevin
really is perfect for Warren gray but
she's not really an actress she can do
whatever she sets her mind to it's
social or who's like a duo oh my god you
know who has to be it Olivia culpo Oh
[ __ ] you think remember and Shay
Mitchell was like 29 plague age 18 year
old [ __ ] no I think they're gonna get
like really I feel like they're gonna
bring like honestly like really really
totally even though like you obviously
can't but I know that would be really
good yeah we just need filler I'm sorry
Liz Gillies Oh done and she has a lot of
faith oh well she was born to play
waldorf yeah I don't know but Blair got
really annoying transient like Fallon
I'm Ryder dive yeah no yeah the problem
with closet world that got so
frustrating is like every single
character like was making the worst
possible decisions for themselves and
usually in shows that I love like that's
reserved for like the main character
teri hatcher
Carrie Bradshaw like all the shows that
I love it's like the main character is
so [ __ ] stupid and like ruins their
lives on purpose but it's like everyone
who Gossip Girl was doing that yeah I
know enter Woodsen oh is this [ __ ] on
earth
yep she was the Carrie Bradshaw but then
they started to make Blair like not
Blair like ya know it's just so
frustrating like when you watch a show
that you like and and one person's
making poor decisions it's like
frustrating cuz you always insert
yourself in the TV show like what would
I do if I was that and when everyone in
the PERT and the entire ensemble is like
being dumb it makes it borderline
impossible to watch yeah I'm trying to
think about how that like what
characters debris on scene won't be
based on the books cuz it'll be totally
new characters did anyone have like a
younger sibling that's not [ __ ] Jenny
Humphrey on
like Harry Styles should be in there ooh
as like a Nate Archibald yeah Noah
Centennial should be in it yeah thing
over him no he's too like all-american
looking we're like no he looks like a
New York City prep kid projectable Artie
Jacob oh lordy and he just did something
with HBO PHP for it yes yeah up again
tomorrow that's a great [ __ ] I mean
he like looks like an eight hour
tomorrow Mikey oh my god that is not so
good that's really good this is fun yeah
and now a younger Jenny Humphrey who's
like someone like a little younger
that's like Sabrina carpenter yeah edgy
she's very edgy and she's not really in
the Disney like seams scene anymore
she's doing crazy stuff now
Wow but we've really put together quite
an ensemble yeah watch out literally not
one of these people not a single one
nobody listens to us even though we're
smart no totally I guess or they'll just
do a bunch of no names and make their
careers which I'm happy to love that
they cast age appropriately like
sometimes it's just stupid like towards
end of Pretty Little Liars I'm like this
is so dumb I wasn't even watching but I
just knew like [ __ ] Lucy Hale was out
here playing six-year-old and it's so
stupid
yeah well now she's gonna be playing a
six-year-old again in candy cane Katy
keen but she looks six she realizes but
still it feels stupid I don't know
Snoopy has a bad example Shay Mitchell
yeah like Shay Mitchell is giving birth
and two years ago she was four in high
school trying bellisario had a kid and
went to the world wedding soda in high
school yeah right exactly
anyways that's exciting usually I'm not
here for reboot news but by the way I
may have a little in a great call we're
like so mad at the public casting people
look like we're literally oh I guess
maybe I'm just not interested in the
Little Mermaid just called conjecture
yeah
we always do this this is called
theorizing but we're not expecting like
we're gonna get mad if they don't choose
who I said right but I really like I did
not see this week reboot coming there's
so many shows every was like I think in
the jewelry union reboot friends like
there's a million shows I thought before
well I drink I like a reboot not a
reunion I mean I mean like already so
like seeing everybody like older comics
world fuller house did a good job yeah
yeah what would you think about a
friends reboot don't think we need it I
don't [ __ ] with perfection exactly like
it was this time capsule and I don't
think
needs to be and there's so much content
there like you're good yeah they gave up
on kind of amuse yeah my dress looks
like [ __ ] on the show I mean my arm is
literally a spaceship like that you
could see from Earth do you know that
this is the 50th anniversary of the moon
landing do you catch any episodes of the
twists while you were gone
no I was taking sleeping pills and
sleeping till 2:00 because we had an
interesting story yesterday oh yeah
about kids these days because of the
it's the 50th anniversary of we went to
the moon in 1969 oh good to see my
tonsils have not affected my vocal cords
and so they asked kids today like what
do you want to be when you grow up you
know cuz it used to just be ever wanted
to be an astronaut I know now the
majority of US children want to be
bloggers and youtubers
wow I'm an inspiration that's so
beautiful
literally the saddest thing I've ever
heard like astronaut was last on the
list I know in five choices I mean
that's just so indicative like about of
generations like I feel like the
generation before us have like real
goals and like wanted to better our
world
we're just getting further and further
away from the notion of flying cars and
had real heroes like you know Buzz
Aldrin and now we have like David Oh
brick but who's a great kid and he's a
great influence but it's like he's not
here Aldrin I don't know he marries his
friend's mom that's pretty funny
no he also like to the thing with a porn
star who everyone says looks like
Margaret I just want to say I loved
Robert Hirsch oh it's nothing Riley read
everyone's been saying that my whole
life I don't see it at all such a
compliment like to look like a porn star
I know I wasn't upset yeah but it's just
like they're really famous well no
important stars can't be ugly like yeah
no it's just like you don't get Ricky
like okay right then have graciously
accepted the roles of Ricky like a job
bafreux and we're just gonna lean into
it but he like had her own talk show I'm
like that's my dream so right you're on
track not even my dream talk show girl
with some other people totally well we
need to talk about Bravo
but first I want to tell you about
broomy because you know I love nice
imbrue Mayhew actually of all the brands
has found to the shows and we love them
all Jackie's [ __ ] obsess for the
roommate every time I come over
she's taking about the dishwasher no
it's really amazing my favorite product
is the wine see later because it fits
it's like it's a insulator for a whole
bottle of wine so it's the size
bottle of wine you pour the wine in
there uncork it keeps it whatever
temperature it's originally at for like
20 over 24 hours you can bring your wine
with you anywhere without worrying about
it
temperature you know pick either the
mobis want a crisp wine with me wherever
I go yeah broomy allows for me happen
and honestly I feel as though my life is
better off for it Jackie loves her room
does she have like a special pink one
yeah no it's like pink and glittery and
then it came with like two matching cups
and like I'm just ready for a picnic at
all time yeah anyways if you're like me
and you hate when your drink gets warm
or just not the temperature that you
want it to be at you should check out
brew mate because it is everything you
need like that's just a wine but it's
really great for a while it's really
great for wine for those tipsy toasters
out there like this is the product you
need in your life they have hops later
slims which are slim can coolers for 12
out slim cans so like one yep yeah white
claw beer and whoa you're a drink of
choice for me it's a bottle of sense err
but you know I think it's actually
pronounced son [ __ ]
but brewery doesn't discriminate so
don't settle for warm alcohol chill out
with your favorite drinks all day long
with brew mate visit brew mate calm and
add code TMT to get 15% off your first
order that's 15% off your first order
when you go to brew mate be are you ma
te comm and add code at TMT it's really
like the best accessory for summer take
it to the beach oh those warm Beach
drinks oh my god and he keep the sand
out of it I know who we need to play as
Kelly Rutherford who quit if altro yes
that's she's so [ __ ] Upper East Side
elite like I love that awesome it also
gets like down and dirty in Brooklyn you
know I look forward to a show like
Gossip Girl that really is like a
magazine about New York because it tells
you about new restaurants what people
are doing what's like what younger does
for for New York honestly it's the way
that I feel like if I lived in LA I feel
like I would watch Vanderpump rules like
with like a magnifying glass because
they go to such fun places like all the
time and Beverly Hills Real Housewives
yeah and they go to like fancy places
like it's really like a tour guide of
fun restaurants fun things to do like
that thing with the door and all the
knocks like I thought that was so fun
then there's live Reno shows in New York
and New York City like they learn every
in New York they're always in the
Hamptons or in the Berkshires so they go
to write for Brooklyn
yeah younger is very like Brooklyn young
professionals scene and the places at
the house I was in New York oh we're
like such a
places like they the housewives like
I've made certain restaurants famous
like boutique and like it let me went
out of business because it was it was
like just categorized as like an old
lady restaurant you know yeah now like
the restaurants they go to it's like a
literally it's poisonous no totally I
always think when I think about the
restaurants they go do I always think
about the place where they made their
own pizza and Jules put a cup in it yeah
a fork a fork and that was really weird
that was really weird but then I also
like want to know what that place is
because I kind of want to go that sounds
like a fun date night yeah or just like
skinny vibes um okay let's talk about
Beverly Hills which was two nights ago
Lisa Vanderpump didn't show up but they
keep alluding to the fact that she like
might show up and then a car pulls up
and it's a GU and it was Camille Lisa
Vanderpump is not showing up no that
would have leaked by now if she had
shown that agreed so where are we at
we're at just like real confusion
because like suddenly there's all this
tension between Camille and Denise and I
love Denise and I'm like here for
everyone depending Denise and before
Camille came down and sat and ruined the
reunion I was really enjoying just like
the nice pleasures of this group of
friends and when they were all like sick
I like I was queen and they didn't mean
it in the sense that I Queen me they
meant like they really are all connected
to require like Kyle and Teddy are best
friends and they way they all would in
like an or if they weren't on a TV show
the way they would normally all hang out
I was like they're all related through
this one friend Kyle who kind of
connects them all and they just like
that they address that because they use
the word queen for Lisa van if I'm in
such a negative way and one like it's a
positive word and that is Kyle really is
like the glue yeah and that's what they
meant and I just love that they all
agreed and like nobody cared that they
said that like I want to be the queen
bee yeah it was like all along no one
wanted to be the Queen themselves they
just didn't want Lisa to be it uh she's
a shitty Queen yeah and no one had
positive relationship like her and Erika
Jayne they don't [ __ ] know each other
no not at all they never became friends
and neither of them really wanted to
like all she the only glue she had was
beefy glue oh yeah Lucifer in an away
looking lamb I can't listen they didn't
like even like recognize the fact that
Kyle and Lisa Rinna are like a litter
wearing the same thing yeah like notice
anything I guess it's just the color of
the season like deletes clips
I love she's gonna Sephora but she's so
cute
imagine how painful that is she's like
parroting yourself I think Dury gets
like the most [ __ ] out of anyone in that
franchise for sure and like she has for
years and now I think
unwarranted and I feel really like badly
for her Susy her watch happens live
looking like literally a star she's a
star like the hair behind she's so
beautiful that she dress everything that
she has she's literally spending
everything every garbage is on looks for
us I loved her when he looked up
initiative I loved when they were
talking about her bank accounts being
president right before he ended and he
was like makes you stress Bulma yeah
[ __ ] love her like really rather John
yeah I can't leave she sound the first
team to run us out in the second seat I
know when Ramona was pretty cool about
it everyone they seemed to really get a
lot in rona Ramona that's the type of
Ramona that I love she obviously like
haven't like three pre-degree she has
before and she was just like really
relaxed and interested in jury storyline
and also talking about herself
sometimes she can like only talk about
her stuff but she's like so mean and
that's like the remember that I hate but
that Ramona I'm watching up inside was
like pink Ramona and that's like the
Ramona she should always be if she wants
to say on TV a hundred percent also when
they played that clip of her not
remembering names
well first they did Kelly Todd and then
Kelly Cod and did his FINA Bridey I was
laughing how that briny scene was awful
like painful to watch the first and the
second time it was painful the second
time oh my god that's so funny I forgot
about the bride a scene that was so oh
hey dr. Sharon Jeezy of it all being a
much up inside like literally love her
so much so happy for her and Ramona was
just like such a great advertisement
I can't believe Ramona's never had a
facelift I know but I can be just look
I've never had a facelift dr. Sherin
easy should have like the faceoff where
they don't steal your face and show you
what you'll look like it backed up to
derbies yeah like oh that I talked
that's what I want to see it like
plastic me ya know if they had showed me
I have I had my before pictures for my
procedure I'm like literally they make
me want to die and like them like truly
like go live in a cave but if she has
shown me like in the moment like a CGI
like not not a hundred percent but like
a realistic version of what I would've
looks like she could have gotten me to
pay triple the price like literally
that's great there's no price I would
put on this chin now yeah the chin
actually keeps me up at night
maintaining the chin yeah well that's
like submission I did it's coming down a
little bit but whatever I got a meeting
uh Beverly Hills Camille showed up
Camille showed up and while I'm
unbelievably anti Camille I felt as
though it was Andy Pettit was Denis and
Camille against each other in relation
to
their divorces I mean Camille saying
that she worked so hard he took me like
two days to realize that she meant she
worked hard like maintaining her
marriage and like being Kelsey's wife I
didn't understand that because she was
comparing Denise actually being a
working mom - Camille working to get
half of her husband's fortune right and
I thought was very interesting I didn't
know that Denise did not take half of
charters she could have took in Charlie
to the cleaners because he was in such a
bad space any judge she as the kids
would have seen that he knows Rena
community property like and he had a
piece of two and a half men from the
very beginning that's probably more than
like one of the friends people like
making milk I'd like over a million in
episode you own that's like the Big Bang
kids like you own so much of the show
like you'll be making money on that till
literally the day your
great-great-great-great graduated style
like it's it's oh it's like a lifetime's
worth of money and I don't need did she
say how much she took no but do you
think Charlie Sheen blow all of his
money that's possible after Janissa
before after she should've taken the
trusteeship yeah just to hold on to
something like and then consider his net
worth
when I was watching it and it only said
ten million which is yelling up because
I'm pretty I feel like I remember
reading that he spent all of his money
on like drugs and hookers and everything
but now the way that she talked and
she's really talked about him so
respectfully because he has become such
a joke like winning like he all those
videos and pictures of him like with
hookers he he is a joke but she really
speaks said him like with such reverence
and respect because he is the father of
her kids and I respect that so much
because she could be an [ __ ] like
everyone else and everyone would agree
with her yeah you know yeah and I
thought it was really interesting that
the only thing he was upset about and
that he was really for her doing the
show was when he said that she brought a
hooker to Thanksgiving but he did and
that's like funny you know it's like
she's mad she denies this his it's like
yeah yeah right cuz when you read about
it in tabloids you're like this isn't
real like but then you hear about it's
like oh it's kind of funny it's kind of
sweet like he brought her home for the
occasion he set a plate like that's the
cute story
I think makes everyone look good oh my
god wait and so been like you know he
pretends like he like hates all these
shows he came in and I was like I'm
watching Beverly Hills if you want to go
watch something in the living room he's
like no I'll I'll sit for a minute oh
and it's not first three and they were
talking about Lisa not being there and
he was like wait
Lisa's not coming and I'm like yeah no
she like got caught in all her [ __ ]
and now she's not
how many more and she got fired whatever
and it's like but I love her I'm like
what so you're getting a divorce
we'd like learning this 30-minute fight
because he thought it was sorry at least
already you made the greatest call one
time that Ben is Lisa Rinna yeah he's
like whispering and everyone's here and
then he's like like he's like I'm and
when he when he found any Vanderpump
Union carries a mistake yeah that is
hilarious cuz I was like that can't that
Walmart since when do you like the
Savannah pump he was like but what how
does it benefit Bruce play like he was
really he always pretends like he
doesn't like the show and I'm like I
know you [ __ ] love it and he's so
interested by it
yeah I'd one more thing to say about the
women of the hills of Beverly Oh
apparently there's like the scene that
they cut where Camille says something
awful that everyone's coming after cuz
she's a what if I weren't a white woman
would you say this to me yeah apparently
gets cut so we'll never know if that's
the truth but it's like a very big rumor
coming around on all like legitimate
media outlets I haven't even seen that
yet but how weird that's really weird
and it's weird that they would cut it
like what's the reason right because it
makes me think of when Kim Zolciak said
that incredibly stupid thing on their
house was in Atlanta about racism being
over yeah like they should have taken
that out if they're gonna take that out
right interesting yeah I need to go look
for it I had what I was gonna say again
and I lost it again I'm sorry it's okay
I'll give you it I need you think about
everyone on the other thing Oh dorita
and Teddy and here's what I think is
crucial but they're trying to highlight
and they're not doing good enough job is
that Lisa Vanderpump is hung up on this
radar online thing because there's a
chance that she's not lying about that
and what the women are saying is
regardless of radar Online and the TMZ
stunt the set up the set up is the big
thing and Lisa it's the bigger it's the
big it's the thing like the rates the
only it's the only thing the news the
accompanying news were just
accoutrements yeah to the set up and she
every time is back into a corner she
brings up like they think I lied about
radar online and you know it's making me
think you know what maybe she actually
didn't because she's covering up the
bigger lie right and like at the end of
the day it doesn't really matter and the
fight was never really about that but
she ended it at that like once they
brought up the radar line thing that's
when she literally stopped filming which
is so stupid and I just I have to give a
major shout-out to whoever edits these
shows because them clipping back to one
Adrian didn't show up and exactly
lisa was the first person to send the
only person everybody s just sat there
anything nobody I truly loved the
hypocrisy of it all yeah like no one
even asked her to speak on it and now
she's speaking to herself a few years
later I'm kucik what southern charm
because I had a lot of thoughts and I
spoke with this is Shep and I was like
you guys have arguably one of the most
successful shows it really is very
consistent the ratings are up there with
some of the best housewife franchise
they always do really well yet you go on
the worst trips and he's again oh we
know we like it the worst trips I think
alike Key West right in an RV and it's
this time they go to Colorado and I'm
like oh you know what I spoke too soon
and they get the fancy bus like the
housewives get and like finally the
southern charm kids are getting some
respect and then they pull up to that
like town house that was like we had
eight bunk beds it was one bedroom
oh the bedroom situation was near but I
thought the houses were nice it was just
it was not what its Rob level chalets go
right I am [ __ ] Aspen like if the
house was in New York went to Aspen even
that house they went to in Vermont oh my
god literally my favorite house ever I
keep trying to find it cuz I want to go
on vacation there like that house takes
a major dump on that to home thing no we
should go to Vermont I know
close note we're like we're the
Kardashians go skiing and like you're so
Bravo like [ __ ] the Housewives of
Atlanta I went to Africa the houses of
New York went to Morocco like the kids
the best trip they've ever had they went
to Denver Beverly has meant to Dubai
right I agree with you on that yeah no
it's just like was making me so sad okay
don't come here them to housewives
because they're not compare them to the
under pump rules now what do you think
they go to Mexico they go more fun they
go to more hotels they leave the Hat
they leave the country yeah they went to
uh did they go to Europe or was that
off-camera that was off-camera Oh
whatever they only really go to Mexico
then yeah that's like solving and Big
Sur
yeah they literally go to Mexico every
night honestly it's a southern term
status but I feel like that makes him
there so kids their kids right in there
not cuz Whitney is like 45 oh my god I
was like really
oh I also caught up on the last two
episodes and I'm really like I don't
like Whitney at all but I really
respected how he defended his mom and I
don't like his mom either but that's
what you do and actually Jacobs that
little piece of [ __ ] talking [ __ ] about
someone's mom like you don't do that and
I really respected how he just was very
straight up and he was like don't
[ __ ] disrespect my mom and I love a
man who
specs and protects his mom I completely
everything out of it really well like he
was also he was like that being rude he
was there to be defensive but also hear
her out you know and then she starts
talking [ __ ] and he's like oh hey [ __ ]
you by Ashley Jacobs is so mentally
unstable I cannot believe that she was
on this show in that chair literally in
that chair and Thomas was here too and
like that we so crazy we didn't know
like it was the first episode of the
season they're like the new girl we're
like sure well we take any Bravo yeah it
was right the episode that had aired
before she came on was when she sat down
with Kathryn at lunch and everything she
was saying about like co-parenting it
would be good you know like she wants to
get along she's saying all the right
things and I really thought that she was
just gonna be like a decent I didn't
know it should be such a controversial
character you know it's like saying that
Leeanne Locken we were like oh she's not
what TV makes her to me even Corinne
like there's so many people TV makes it
out to be crazy and like we always get
people the benefit of the doubt Maggie
hadn't even meet her as me crazy yet so
we were just like oh yeah
Bravo a Bravo cast member is always
welcome on the show of any show so I
always think about that like how we were
literally in her presence because she's
literally like a ghost
she's like a legendary ghost who I came
and went and like she actually looked
great when she came on to the barbecue
oh when I want to record the Limehouse
girl because I got to starting to like
her because I'm so intrigued by her
family and she works at the inn and like
she owns all these properties and she's
inheriting 50 million dollars worth of
property I really like her but I don't
like how she invited Ashlee and I know
that was probably like a production
thing yes and you know what it made for
interesting TV I don't mind the chin
bite at her and what she said me since
she's like I'm it and actually because
she said she wanted to apologize to
everyone and like let me give her that
chance she's my friend
and then the minute that Ashlee was a
beast like a license done with her yeah
and I thought she handled everything
really well and I was like boyfriend's
really cute and but there's no long
they're not together right now she's
with someone else I it's looking at her
Instagram Khushi follow me hey girl
and she has a really cute new boyfriend
I like her boyfriend now he like sit
down with the guys he just like sits and
he doesn't bother it's hilarious that
he's from New Jersey man oh my yank
that's hilarious
I just she's wearing on me and when she
said she had fifty million dollars worth
of property coming how old when she
didn't uh did she say but I think she's
really like probably when people die I
just thought that was wildly interesting
also while they interesting that Craig
said that Whitney has 100
dollars coming Terry oh yes Craig was
being a [ __ ] that job bus I don't
blame him because 40 hour travels I it's
torture and like don't come for me I
won't to offer you but like he was
starting with everyone I'm like I just
love when Chelsea goes off on people
like when Chelsea went off on Ashley on
that boat last season like when Chelsea
goes like you could suck my [ __ ] dick
you Busey like she becomes Britney
Cartwright yeah I love her no I love her
too I just feel like something happened
and they're not telling us yeah I felt
weird also the way that Whitney treats
Craig would set me off too and also when
you're traveling and then there's not
one person who doesn't stop complaining
it's like shut the [ __ ] up we're all in
this together like yeah you think you're
better you don't wanna get on a bus take
a [ __ ] goober like leave us alone I
got that but he dragged that on
literally for 20 minutes and he was so
weird and funny also I don't know if I'm
the only one but I really ship Austin
and Madison okay I was really loving
them too they were being so cute when
they almost kissed in the hot tub like
with her eyes closed I was dying I was
like they're not gonna kiss again for
the first time in front of everyone yeah
they didn't thank God no but then they
came back together I was like sad I know
when like he wanted to kiss her and she
wanted him to kiss her and they did it I
just love I say goodnight like 30 times
cuz no one wanted to like end the night
yeah I really like Austin and I just
want happiness for him and I really
shipped him and Chelsea and like I still
hold out like a little bit of hope but I
really think like she's too smart driven
and like she's just not the right girl
for him she's too like witty you know no
no she's not the girl for him and I
still I know everyone that his friends
don't like Madison and they say like
they don't know what they see but like I
see it they definitely have like
chemistry and a connection and I'm
really enjoying her on the show like I'm
ready for to get to know more of her I
think she's actually an interesting girl
I think she's divorced oh yeah and she I
think she's like young I feel like she
has an interesting story and I'm down
for a full-time cast member here I have
a final controversial statement because
we know her we love her and I do like
her and this is not saying anything like
bad about her or the way that I feel
about her but I just like cannot stand
hearing about how hard Cameron's life is
so frustrating and like are you kidding
me like your husband's a doctor like you
don't have to work you choose to work
and you work part-time and like your mom
comes and helps you all the time and you
choose not to have a nanny
even though you have a huge house and
you're making a ton of money from this
stupid show like you're all you do is
complain about
how hard your life is like I'm not a mom
so I can't even compare but it's like
stop complaining because like you have
it so much better off than so many other
people I just recognizes that with every
complaint she always says like and I
know I am NOT an efficient to complain
but she's allowed to feel how she feels
yes I'm just over hearing about it
okay that's there but that's just her
story right now it's boring but I'm
liking her story about her getting drawn
back yes me check
hilarious yes and I want her to smoke
weed yeah she's so like perfect it's so
weird how you can like films so openly
about like drugs in Colorado like they
would never smoke speak about weed in
Charleston so the way they were all
talking about weed like it was the
devil's dirt like it's those people get
high all the time I feel right I mean I
don't know them but everyone gets high
all the time they were talking about it
was like dropping acid that's the second
time I've said that on the show today
now it's an acid rather than show but
acting like who are you gonna are you
he's good and like being like judge like
a little joke it's like it's like
wouldn't really I went to Amsterdam
basically that was a long time ago and
they have kids like we it is very normal
I'm sure things are different in the
south but how different can they be also
you're on like a TV show on Bravo like
right up to 2019 I don't know I just
thought it was like a little like so
fake yeah yeah those are my thoughts do
you watch Shep and I mean Austen and
Craig I watch it I know I did it it was
a really funny episode like everything
was going wrong oh really nice phone was
like ringing and they like was yeah I
think was like you know in our show like
when our phones play the show like weird
chatter and they couldn't figure out
where they did a funnel and all got over
the floor oh I saw it all spilled on
Craig's big pants yeah it was just a
funny show all I couldn't happen and
they like couldn't get their thoughts
together and they were speaking on
things happening in the show but like
not saying anything it was just funny
would you buy one of Craig's pillows for
$75 uh depends on the design honestly
oh he should be some toasty ones that
kind of hurts on these chairs I could
use a pillow yeah I should get some we
should get pillows that's a cute idea I
bet he has a fabric from that store
Kathryn was very quiet this episode yeah
she's just like I prefer her don't stay
out of it you know yeah because she's
always taking like the
doesn't make your money feed your kids
and just sit down yeah I don't I just I
like her presents though and I like her
doing well and I also she was so much
her and her conversation with Whitney
and he was acting like a third grader so
oh my god I didn't insult her third I am
if there's anything more insulting than
someone denying that they hooked up with
you right and you go and while you're
sitting me like there's no pheromone
except for all of America in their homes
and you're just gonna like keep denying
it and then he gets up from his chair
he's like being a freak yeah no he's he
is literally the weirdest human being
alive yeah I look I do not [ __ ] with him
and his family and it's so weird that he
comes off so weird on the show yet he's
a producer so he has say over how he
comes off but he right that's the best
he can do that was the best edit he
could have gotten from that awful scene
no and like all seasons he's just so
weird scene he's yeah when they when he
had that house in LA and like everyone
came to visit him and he was being like
such a freak about LA like I would have
learned with it I would have cut that
entire episode literally mom I need to
focus on my art right now totally no and
I watched the first episode again when
he's like he lives with his mom and his
room is dirty and she was like clean it
up she was like don't tell me what to do
mom and it's like you're recording
you're 40 like when you live in your
parents it's their rules Yeah right
like it or get out so that was crazy we
have New York housewives tonight which
we will recap tomorrow I'm very excited
part - oh no part to a Virginian
Bethenny's just been looking so good at
this unit and her facial reactions to
all the insane [ __ ] Louetta saying it's
just like true chief gold we had we
didn't recap part one but now we'll just
do them both together but I forgot
everything really nothing happened
I just forgot I I've been forgetting my
feelings on TV shows well you know what
I was thinking this morning my amnesia
is really debilitating in a lot of ways
but it's especially debilitating when I
have to take pills certain times a day I
can't remember if I took them that
morning like it's really bad I should
write things down I know that is crazy
to think about it because I think I took
my second pill last night I got to take
this antibiotic twice a day and I don't
remember I think we can count the bills
annual oh oh that's a good idea genius
that's why she paid the big bucks
um okay thank you guys in a long a show
so glad to be back thank you for
welcoming me back remember August 2nd my
single comes out tickets available to
girl with no job tour the dirty jeans
tour at girls no job calm coming up I
have
tickets up to the Charleston show
Virginia Beach and Richmond Virginia
which will be super fun and then also we
are lighting up Vegas September first I
can't we got to go back to Vegas I'm
literally gonna throw up like the
opposite of everything we did we could
yes I chose I wanna go the spa sponge
anyone [ __ ] Bushman okay yeah there
were a lot of shows I want to see Brooke
sing down oh yeah yeah yeah I want me to
acts but there's a huge billboard of my
face in the Mirage Hotel which is so
crazy so if you're in Vegas go check it
out take a picture of it and also get
tickets to The Mirage show at the tarifa
store theater girls no job huh exciting
also my summer presets are out dropped
yesterday Jack I lose them all but every
picture Vegas I check you out the
enhanced preset is literally the only
preset I need in my life is it is this
your favorite pack
it's definitely perfect for my tone it's
like my complexion and also like my
dirty apartment
oh sweet yeah it brightens everything
this is my favorite pack sweet or maybe
I'm just like so used to the other ones
I'm like over them you know totally
they're not like matte it's like we're
not even learning magic trick over and
over like you know all the secrets and
yeah this is just such a great summer
vibe it's just so great I like really
can't recommend enough
oh thanks to Jackie O Flo calm get your
presets boobies up flow with the w or
flow with the W if I like Aunt Flo
yeah actually and Flo is no W no and
flow from the insurance doesn't double
you know so we're we're pro W cool a
chance for Weinreb the show then you
guys so listening to the morning show
some linen morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube to make sure to like
this video subscribe leave us a nice
comment we're also available as a
podcast if you cannot watch everyday
podcasts are available on Spotify iTunes
stitcher public radio anywhere you can
listen to podcasts or subscribe over
there leave a five star review about how
were the most beautiful set and skinny
and smart girls you've ever met in your
life we love you more than anything to
me we'll see you tomorrow
you